The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: All right.
Good morning, everyone.
Let's get started.
A new module today--
we're going to spend a few
lectures on
randomized algorithms.
And so not only will we look
at slightly different ways
of solving old problems
like sorting, we'll also
look at how we can analyze
this new kind of algorithm that
generates random numbers
in order to actually make
decisions as it's executing
and that we'll end up obviously
with the analysis that
gives us the expected run
time of the algorithm--
for example,
whether the algorithm is going
to produce a correct result
or not, with what probability
will this algorithm
produce a correct result.
So I'll talk a
little bit about why
we're interested in
randomized algorithms
in a couple of minutes,
but let me define
what a randomized algorithm,
or a probabilistic algorithm,
is to start things off.
And so randomized
algorithm is something
that generates a random number.
Now, this would be a coinage
flip, but more often than not,
you're generating a real number
that comes from a sudden range.
Sometimes you're
generating a vector.
You'll see a couple
of different examples
here in today's
lecture and in section.
And it's going to make
decisions based on this value,
based on r's actual value.
Now, you can imagine that an
algorithm would be recursive,
and at every level
of recursion, it's
going to generate a random r.
So when you're executing at a
particular level of recursion,
you may be doing different
things based on r.
And not only that, if you
re-run the algorithm again
on the same input, the
execution will be different
because you're resuming
a true random number
generator as opposed
to a pseudo random one.
And the r's that
you're going to get
at different levels of recursion
or through the execution
of the algorithm are going to
be different from the first time
to the second time.
So on the same input on
different executions,
two things might happen.
The algorithm may run for a
different number of steps.
So you might get lucky
on the first execution,
and the algorithm finishes,
let's say at 100 time units.
The second time around,
it takes a long time.
It takes 700 time units.
Our goal here is
to try and analyze
what this probabilistic
runtime would
be to ask for an expectation,
to be able to compute
an expectation for the
runtime, or-- if you're
talking about a
different scenario
where different executions--
I could actually
produce different outputs.
And in this case, it's
possible that one or more
of these outputs are incorrect.
You actually get
the wrong answer.
And obviously, that's
going to happen
with a certain probability.
You're going to have
to decide or analyze
what that probability is.
And generally speaking,
we won't be happy
with a high probability of
error, as you can imagine.
And we'd like to set
up an algorithm such
that you can reduce that
probability of incorrect output
to be something
really, really small.
And it might take
you longer to get
to that low level
of incorrect output
in one case for a certain set
of inputs versus another case.
So that's this set up here
in terms of randomized.
You're going to have
algorithms that-- you can think
of them as probably correct.
So these are
algorithms-- you want
to think of them as
probably correct,
and they do have a name.
They're called Monte
Carlo algorithms.
And then you have algorithms
that are probably fast.
So-- indicates a
probably correct--
you could have a constant
probability that they're
going to give you the
correct answer, 99%.
And you could obviously
try and parametrize that.
In the case of
probably fast, you
say things like, it runs an
expected polynomial time.
And really what that
means is that you may have
to run it for more information.
So rather than taking 100
iterations or 100 steps
to sort something, it
might take you 110.
But in the case
of probably fast,
you do get the sorted
result at the end.
And when the algorithm
has finished execution,
you do get that sorted
result at the end.
So it's correct and probably
fast or probably correct
and deterministically fast.
OK.
And this is Las Vegas.
So you have Monte Carlo
versus Las Vegas here.
So yesterday, it
occurred to me--
and I've taught this
class a bunch of times--
but it occurred to
me for the first time
last night that there
should be algorithms
that are probably correct
and probably fast,
which means that
they're incorrect
and slow some of the time.
Right?
So what do you think those
algorithms are called?
Sorry.
What?
AUDIENCE: T?
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: The T?
Oh.
Oh!
That deserves a Frisbee.
Oh my goodness!
[LAUGHS] All right.
There you go.
All right.
Now, they're not called
the T. So we should write
that down so everyone knows.
Probably correct
and probably fast,
which is I guess they
don't get you anywhere.
I don't know what that
means-- incorrect and so
in the case of the T.
So the MB/TA.
Any guesses?
I mean, think about what we
have for Monte Carlo, Las Vegas.
Extrapolate.
These are the kinds
of questions you're
going to get on your quiz.
I guess you guys
don't gamble you.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Atlantic City.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Atlantic City.
That deserves a Frisbee.
Yeah.
Absolutely right.
That It turns out
Atlantic City isn't
a name that's really
caught on, but it
was in terms of being
used in this context.
Most of the time, if you do
have a probably correct probably
fast algorithm,
you can convert it
into a Monte Carlo algorithm
or a Las Vegas algorithm.
There are some prime
testing algorithms
to test whether a particular
number is a prime or not
that run in probabilistic
polynomial time,
and they may incorrectly tell
you that the number is a prime.
So that's an example of an
Atlantic City algorithm.
We won't actually
do Atlantic City.
What we'll do is
we'll take a look
at a couple of different
algorithms, and both of these
will motivate why randomized
algorithms are interesting.
The Monte Carlo example is
checking matrix multiply.
So you've gotten a couple
of square matrices.
Both of them are
n by n matrices,
and you multiply them out--
A times B, and you produce C.
And so you got the C matrix.
And rather than re-multiplying
and checking the result,
you'd like to do
something better.
You'd like to verify
with some probability
that you can parametrize
that the output
matrix is in fact the product
of the two input matrices.
And so that's a
randomized algorithm
that's a Monte Carlo because
you're not guaranteeing
that that output matrix
is in fact the product
of the first two matrices
or the operand matrices,
but you're getting a good
sense of how likely that is.
And you can kind of squish
that probability of error
down to however low you want
it to be except you have to run
the algorithm for longer.
So that's an example
of Monte Carlo.
Now, quicksort.
It doesn't make sense to
say-- I guess you could--
but it doesn't
make too much sense
to say that you have
an almost sorted array.
What does that mean exactly?
You have to categorize that.
So quicksort is an
example where you're
guaranteed to get a sorted
array at the end of it.
So it's correct.
You will get a sorted ray.
That's what you wanted--
descending order,
ascending order.
But it might not run
in order n log n time.
That's expected time.
Order n log n is expected time.
And so that's what probably
fast would correspond to.
All right?
So that's the set up.
You can kind of see why these
are interesting because you
could imagine that in
practical scenarios,
you might want to
do some checking
in a probabilistic way.
And you want to do that without
having to redo all the work.
Obviously you don't want your
checker for matrix multiply
to be as slow as
multiplying two matrices.
Otherwise it makes no sense.
So let's dive into
matrix product
and our first example of a
probably correct algorithm,
or Monte Carlo algorithm.
So what I want to do
here is C equals A
times B. And the simple
algorithm-- I guess,
those of us who
went to high school,
myself included, did my four
years-- know of an n cube
algorithm-- or
learned it back then.
It simply corresponds to
taking rows and columns,
and you get an entry.
You have n square
entries that you
need to compute corresponding
to the output matrix C.
And you're going to do order n
multiplications and additions,
but we're really going to
consider multiplications here.
When I talk about
n here, it's not
the total number of operations.
It's the number of
multiplications.
And the reason
for that is-- this
may have gone away a little bit,
but it's still probably true--
that multiplication,
in computers, it
takes longer to multiply
two numbers, integers
are floating point numbers,
than adding numbers.
It used to be much
more dramatic,
the differences
between multiplying
and add in computers.
But thanks to pipelining
and lots of optimizations,
multiplies are
actually very fast.
But they are, obviously, a
more sophisticated operation
than addition.
So we'll be counting multiplies.
So when you've seen
Karatsuba divide and conquer
for multiply, back end in 006.
Remember that we were
counting multiplications,
and we were actually trading off
multiplications for additions.
We were trying to shrink
that number associated
with the complexity
of the algorithm
when counting the
number of multiplies.
And we actually
counted the number
of additions that
were going up--
at least from a constant
factor standpoint,
not necessarily from an
asymptotic complexity
standpoint.
And so that's simple algorithm.
You probably heard of Strassen.
Some of you might have seen it.
Essentially what
happens with Strassen
is you multiply two two
by two matrices using
seven multiplications
as opposed to eight.
Now, if you do that-- and this
is similar to the Karatsuba
analysis-- you can
do this in n raised
to log 2 7 time,
which is essentially
n raised to 2.81 time.
And so rather than n cubed, you
can go down to n raised 2.81.
Now it turns out people
have obviously not
stopped with this.
You can go to n raised to 2.70
by doing something of the order
of 143,000 multiplications
for 70 by 70 matrices.
So you can play around.
Just like you had Toom-Cook.
I don't know if you remember
that or it got covered--
but Karatsuba could get
generalized into this thing
called Toom-Cook.
And the same thing, Strassen--
you could go off and divide
and conquer whose base case is
not two by two, but 70 by 70,
and that improves things.
But it turns out there's other
arithmetic series summation
ways.
And so a famous algorithm
that's up until 2010
was the best complexity
algorithm known.
It's Coppersmith-Winograd,
which is 2.376.
And then at some point, we
had a faculty candidate here
who either shrunk this
from 2.376 to 2.373.
And it turns out that there were
two different researchers who
came up with a 2.373, but
this particular candidate
in the sixth decimal place won.
So she had an eight.
Person had a nine or something.
But anyway, all of
these are impractical.
OK.
You don't want to use them.
The constant factors
associated with these things
are much larger than
what you have here.
The constant factors here,
I guess it's one, right?
Makes sense that it
would be one, forgetting
the additions of course.
So if you have large
constant factors,
then you need a billion by
billion matrix in order to win.
And if you have billion by
billion matrices that you want
to multiply, do something else.
OK.
You don't want to go there.
Even in the day of the internet,
it's not going to work.
So what we'd like to do
now is do something better.
So we will try-- given that
theoretical computer science
class, it makes sense to say
that our verification algorithm
should be better than n raised
to 2.376 or 2.3-whatever.
Right?
Otherwise, it doesn't feel good.
So what we'd like to
do-- and we can do this--
is try and get an order n
square algorithm-- that's this.
So it's probably correct
Monte Carlo algorithm
where if you have
A times B equals C,
then the probability of
the output equals yes is 1.
So in fact, if you got it
right, then the verifier
is going to not give
you a false negative.
It's not going to say--
no, you got it wrong--
when you got it right.
But it could give you up a false
positive with some probability
where you have the probability
of output equals yes,
and that's a false positive.
But you can bound that
to be less than half.
OK.
So it's going to say, yes.
So obviously, if the verifier
kept saying yes all the time,
you wouldn't have this.
It wouldn't be very interesting.
I would be constant time, but
it wouldn't be very interesting.
What is interesting here is
that when they're not equal,
you're going to get an incorrect
result with some operand
on the probability.
So you say, about one half
seems kind of high-- 50%
flipping a coin.
The good news is that
these algorithms,
you can run them over and over.
You can run this
checker over and over.
And as long as executions
are independent,
and you can certainly
ensure that they're
independent by ensuring
that the randomness from one
execution to another-- the
flipping of the coins--
are independent.
OK.
And so that's
relatively easy to do,
in certainly all of the
scenarios we'll be looking at.
In 046, it's
relatively easy to do.
You can now drive
this probability down
to one quarter
with two executions
because you'll just
check different things.
And then one eighth with
three and so on and so forth.
So that's what's cool about it.
And now, if you can
look at the runtime,
you say, well, runtime
still order n square.
That's the beauty of
this because I'm just
putting an extra constant
factor here where
I have k n square,
where k is a constant.
And effectively, I have
this nice relationship
in terms of the
probability of error
going down to 1 divided
by 2 raised to k.
And what I have here
is a k n square.
So that's what's cool about it.
And obviously, k n square
is 2 order n square
in a polynomial time, and but
the probably correct aspect
of it gets better and better.
OK.
Any questions so far?
All right.
Good.
So what we're going to do
is this algorithm actually
works for arbitrary matrices--
the structure at least.
We're going to assume that the
matrix entries are Boolean.
They're going to work in
the finite field mod 2.
And it's just is
an easier proof.
It's easier to see.
So the complexities
are all the same.
You're still
multiplying numbers.
They happen to be small.
And multiplication
cost you one operation.
And you need to do n cubed
multiplies to actually get
the C matrix, and you have to
verify it order n square time.
And so the number of
multiplies, again,
that you want to use in
your verification algorithm
has to be order n square.
We're ignoring the additions.
So that's what we'd like out
of our matrix product checker,
and the algorithm
we're going to look at
is called Freivald's algorithm,
cute little algorithm, that
does the following.
So the algorithm itself
is very straightforward,
in couple of lines, a
minute or so to describe,
and the interesting aspect of
it is the analysis-- the fact
that you can show this.
That's the cool part.
If you couldn't
show that, there's
nothing cool about
this algorithm.
So we're going to choose
a random binary vector.
So there you go.
Here's your randomness.
And this binary vector,
every time you run it,
as the k increases here,
the random binary vector
is different from
one to another.
That's important.
You can't run the
same thing again
and then expect a different
result. That's called insanity.
But you are going
to assume that given
that we are working
in the binary space
and this is a binary
vector, you're
going to assume that r i equals
1 is half independently for i
equals 1 through n.
And the algorithm
essentially is this--
we're going to do a bunch
of matrix vector multiplies.
An n by n matrix multiplied
by an n by n matrix
gives you an n by n matrix,
and that's your n cubed.
So these are all--
I think I said this,
but I should've
written this down--
these are all square
matrices that are n by n.
And that's where
you get your n cube.
A matrix vector
would be something
where you have-- typically
we'd have a column vector here.
You're going to get
something like that,
and you have n square
multiplications here.
You're going to
grab one of these
and then multiply it by
that and get an entry here.
And that obviously
is n multiplications,
but you only have n elements
to produce here in this vector.
So you only got n square.
That make sense?
And so what we're going to do
is, we're going to take this r,
and we're going to
compute A times B r.
And so the brackets are
important because it
says that you're going
to compute what's
inside the brackets first.
Otherwise, it would be
a problem because you'd
be multiplying A times B. And
obviously, that's order n cube.
Right?
You don't want that.
So A times Br equals Cr.
OK.
So r, remember, is
a column vector.
And C is an n by
n matrix as our A
and B. We're going
to output yes.
Else-- if these
two are not equal,
you're going to output no.
OK?
And so that's it.
That's one run of the
algorithm, generator random r
and do the multiplication
as you see here.
So let's be clear
about complexity,
and let's make sure we
understand the simpler
aspects of the
algorithm before we
get into the analysis
associated with bounding
the false positive probability.
The hard part is
going to be bounding
the false positive probability.
But the easy part is
first, the complexity.
So how many matrix vector
products am I doing here?
How many matrix
vector products am I
doing here in this check on
one iteration of algorithm?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Three.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Three.
All right.
You need to stand up.
This is fun.
This is the hardest throw
I've had to make in 6046.
I got to put this down.
Warm up a little bit.
It's kind of cold.
Whoa.
Terrible!
All right.
The person who gets up
and gets that owns it,
and we're going
to do this again.
All right.
Let's see how long this takes.
AUDIENCE: Is this
part of my trial?
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Yes.
Well, the first one failed.
False whatever, right?
[LAUGHTER]
I got a few more.
[LAUGHS]
All right.
Let me see.
I think I need to go here.
This is good.
And I need to be-- all right.
Number three.
Thank you.
[CLAPPING]
So it was three.
Three.
Perfect.
Three matrix vector products
because I got to do this.
That's the matrix
vector product.
Remember I'm getting a column
vector out of this, which
is important, and then
I'm going to multiply
this matrix with a column
vector, matrix vector
product number two.
And then there's a matrix
vector product over here.
So then at that
point-- do you remember
I have a vector and a vector.
And checking the
equivalence of two vectors
is simply checking the
equivalence of each element
in the vector 1 by one.
So first one, same
as the first one.
Second one, same
as the second one.
Et cetera.
And so this is order
n square, but three
is something that is worth
thinking about simply
because every once
in a while, we're
interested in constant factors.
And the other thing that's
interesting about this--
make sure I write this--
let me write this over
here-- that you are going
to-- if A B equals C,
then there's no issue
associated with error here.
So there's no notion
of a false negative
because if AB equals C,
then you know, thanks
to the associativity of
matrix multiplication--
be it whether they're n
by n matrices or columns--
you have this relationship here.
And I hope you can
read it at the back.
Essentially what I have
here is if AB equals C.
So if in fact, the matrix
multiply happened correctly,
I'm in a situation where it is
clear that A Br equals this,
thanks to this associativity
of matrix multiply.
And that of course, is
exactly the same as Cr.
So that should convince
you, thanks to associativity
of matrix multiply that you
don't have any false negatives
in this algorithm.
Make sense?
So we're all good.
All we have to do, given what
we have with respect to Frievald
is to do this part
here, which is going
to take a little bit of doing.
And the challenge always
with simple algorithm
is you don't quite
know why they work.
And then of course, you have
sophisticated algorithms,
and you don't quite
know why they work.
So this will take a few minutes.
It's not super complicated,
and there's a little insight,
as always, with
these things that
are not immediately obvious.
But we'll have to look
at the number of r's.
So you have an r vector that
you've generated randomly,
and it may be a bad vector.
It may be a vector that doesn't
show you that the product
matrix has an incorrect entry.
Remember there's n square
entries in this matrix.
Exactly one of them may be
wrong, and you need to find it.
Right?
So there may be a lot of
entries which are all correct,
but you've got to find that
one entry that's incorrect.
And so you could miss it.
A given r vector might
miss it, and of course,
if you keep generating
the r's, you'd
like to find it and declare that
the matrices weren't multiplied
correctly and that probability
is what we have to compute.
So we want to get this
result where we are analyzing
the correctness in the case.
You've already analyzed
the correctness
in the case where AB
equals C, but now we
have to analyze the
correctness in the case
where AB is not
equal to C. Right?
And so the claim is that
if AB is not equal to C,
then the probability
of ABr not equal to Cr
is greater than
or equal to half.
So this is greater
than or equal to.
Over there, I'm just talking
about the false negative
probability where I'm actually
getting an incorrect yes when
you have the matrices
being multiplied wrongly,
incorrectly.
And so that's why I get--
this is what I want.
I want there to be a greater
than one half probability for r
to have discovered that, for
r to have discovered that.
OK?
I'll stop for
questions in a second,
but let me do a little bit more.
I'm going to compute
the difference matrix,
and I'm not computing this
because obviously this
would take a while to compute.
It's just for the
purpose of analysis.
I'm going to look at the
difference matrix D equals AB
minus C because
you want D to be 0.
And that we're going to
do some analysis that
says-- we are going
to try and find
these non-zero entries
in D because, clearly,
the non-zero entries
in D tell you
if there's non-zero entry in
D, you got a problem here.
The matrices weren't
multiplied properly.
So that's why we have D here.
Don't think of it as we're
actually computing that.
So what we'd like
is to, as I said,
discover these entries
where our hypothesis now
is that D is not equal
to 0 because that's
the case we're considering.
We know that D is not equal to 0
if the matrices were multiplied
incorrectly.
And when I say D
is not equal to 0,
it means that there are n square
entries in D, and one of them
is not 0.
They all have to
be identically 0.
That's all it means.
D not equal to 0 means one
entry at least is not 0.
So now what we need to do is
we need to show that there are
many r-- it's a binary
vector of length n,
and you can obviously
think about two ways to n
possibilities with respect to r.
And what we really
want to show is
that there's a large
fraction-- more than half
of the r's are going to actually
discover that the matrices were
multiplied incorrectly.
OK.
So we want to show that
there are many r's such
that Dr is not equal to 0.
And because if Dr
is not equal to 0,
then you're obviously
going to discover
that ABr is not equal to Cr.
So if ABr is not
equal to Cr, that's
identical to saying the
Dr is not equal to 0.
That make sense?
So specifically, if
you look at the claim
and writing it in
terms of Dr, you
want to say that the
probability of Dr not equal to 0
is greater than or equal to
half for a randomly chosen r.
And so that's it.
That's the setup
that we have to show.
We have to do a counting
argument corresponding
to these r vectors that are
being generated randomly.
So let's do that.
So the general argument
we're going to make here
is simply that we're going
to-- roughly speaking--
if you're going to look at
a bad r-- what's a bad r?
And bad r is something
that doesn't discover
the incorrect multiplication.
That's what a bad r is.
So you're D is not equal
to 0, but Dr equals 0.
OK.
That's a bad r, right?
It's quite possible that
that would be the case.
And so you want to
try and figure out
how many of these
bad r are there
because those are
the ones that are
causing the false negatives.
Right?
So that counting argument is the
crux of the proof of the claim.
So let's look at that.
And what we're going to do is,
we're going to pick a bad r,
and we're going
to say I there are
these good r's that are
associated with this bad r.
And for every bad
r, there's a good r.
And a good r is something
that actually discovers
the incorrect multiply.
And given that for every
bad r there's a good r,
half of the arts are good r.
That's it.
So I'll write it down.
That's the essence
of the argument.
And I'm go a little more slowly
so hopefully you'll get that.
So let's look at the case where
Dr equals 0 case because that's
the interesting case.
That's the case
where the r is bad
even though we had an
incorrect multiply,
and you get this-- I should have
said you get a false positive.
So I'm sorry.
I think just before,
I said false negative,
but I meant false positive.
So you have a false
positive in this case,
and D equals AB minus
C not equal to 0
implies there exists
an i and j such
that Dij is not equal to 0.
OK?
And there's just one
entry at least-- if you
say the matrix is
not equal to 0,
there's got to be an entry
that's not equal to 0.
So let's take a
look at that entry,
and let's just draw it out.
That's my D matrix.
And there's going
to be an i and a j.
So that's my ith row
and my jth column.
And there you go.
I have an entry here which is
Dij, and I'm just picking that.
I don't care what i
and j are, but there's
got to be an entry
that's not equal to 0.
Now I'm going to
create a vector, v. So
this vector is not r.
It's a vector v that is
chosen deterministically given
the Dij where it's got 0's
everywhere except it at vj.
So if this the jth
entry column-wise,
everywhere else you got 0.
And you just got
the one associated
with the-- going
downward-- the jth entry.
OK?
So it's a one one-hot
vector, if you will.
It's got one, one.
So now, if you multiply
these two things out,
you know that you're
going to get something,
and we're going to
can call this Dv.
So you take D and
you multiply it
by v-- matrix
multiplied by a vector.
You're guaranteed, given
that all of these are 0,
when I do my this
times that plus this
times this plus this
times this, all of these
are going to produce 0.
This times 1 is going to produce
something that's non-zero,
and then all of the other
ones are going to produce 0.
So I'm just adding a bunch of
0's to this non-zero multiplied
by one.
So I'm going to get
something that's non-zero.
Right?
All make sense?
So I'm going to
see something here,
which is the jth entry
that's not equal 0.
And so that implies that
Dv is not equal to 0.
And in particular, what
I'm saying is Dv of j--
so if I just look at that
entry that is identically
Dij, which is not equal to 0.
Because I'm multiplying it by
1 and I'm adding a bunch of 0's
to it.
That's it.
OK.
Yeah.
A question.
AUDIENCE: Is it Dv of j or of i?
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: So
I picked the j here.
So I think I'm
going j, j, right?
That make sense?
If j was 7 and this
is 7 down, then it
would be the seventh
[INAUDIBLE] because this
is going to turn into that.
OK?
Now, either way, if I
picked it in the middle,
it doesn't really matter.
The point is there's
going to be one entry.
So hang in there.
There's going to be one
entry that's nonzero
if you didn't quite get that.
So Dij is not 0.
And this is one more
observation we're
going to make in order to do
the counting of these bad r's
because this is a bad
r that we're looking
at if you say that Dr equals 0.
You've created a v that
has nothing to do with r,
but we're going
to use the v to go
from a bad r, which is our
example here, to a good one.
That's pretty much it.
That's the last step here.
So what we're going
to do, is we're
going to take any r that can
be chosen by our algorithm
such that Dr equals
0 because that's
the case that we're looking at.
And we're going to compute
r prime, which is r plus v.
And just remember this
is mod 2 arithmetic.
You're only going
to get 0's and 1's.
So if you have 1 plus
1, it gives you 0.
Obviously 0 plus 0 gives you 0.
And the other cases are clear.
And this plus here,
remember, is also--
the other thing that's important
is this is not only mod 2.
These are all vectors.
So r is a vector, and you can
think of it as a column vector.
That's how I drew it.
You're adding up a
column vector with a v.
That's the column vector
the way I drew that.
You could do it with rows if you
like, but it's just notation.
And you're going to
compute an r prime here.
What can you say about Dr prime?
Someone?
Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It's not 0.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: It's not 0.
And I'll give you a
Frisbee, but then you
can explain-- can you
stand up a little?
I don't want to take
this lady's head off.
So can you explain why?
AUDIENCE: Because
r prime is r plus v
and Dr gives you Dr
plus DB is not 0.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
Absolutely right.
So essentially what
we have is this
is simply Dr plus v. 0
plus Dv, not equal to 0.
Do we like yellow
or do we like white?
Yellow's fine.
So that's pretty much it.
So what's cool about
this- is this final step,
which I think you've gotten,
but I'm just going to say it out
loud now, which is that r to r
prime is 1 to 1 for any given r
such that Dr equals 0, given
the situation where capital D is
not equal to 0, and
there's some Dij--
and there could be many Dij's.
I just need one.
I've constructed, based on
that Dij, this v vector which
has the jth entry corresponding
to the v vector being a 1
with all of the other
entries being a 0.
But I can now create an r to
r that is 1 to 1 in the sense
that if r prime equals
r plus v and that equals
r double prime plus v-- so if
I ever have a situation where
in order to show
there's one-to-one,
I want to say that it's not too
many-to-one or even two-to-one.
So if I have an r prime
that equals r plus v
and you tell me that r prime
also equals r double prime plus
v, I can make the argument
that r and r double prime
are exactly the same.
So then r equals r double prime.
So what am I saying there?
I'm just saying that for any
given r that has Dr equals 0,
I can twiddle the jth element of
that r and go from 0 to 1 or 1
to 0.
If you tell me that there's a
Dij somewhere in that matrix
that is nonzero and I do that
little twiddle-- remembers
it's all 0's and 1's Boolean
matrices-- so if I do
one twiddle, it's one-to-one.
If I do two twiddles and I go
1 to 0, I'm back to 1 again.
And that's all this says.
Because you have mod 2.
That's all that says.
So one little
tweak-- and I'm going
to be able to take a bad r
and turn it into a good r
because the good r, the
r prime in this case,
had Dr prime not equal to 0.
And that's it.
That's my counting argument,
and all that remains
is to essentially close
this by sayiny-- just
to write this out to
get to the final claim
and get the one half--
the one-to-one essentially
gives you the one half.
At least half of these things
are going to be good r's.
If you had I Dr that's
not equal to 0--
and that's the case that
you have here-- then we're
going to discover
an r prime such
that the Dr prime is not
equal to 0 and r to r
prime is a one-to-one mapping.
So the number of
r prime for which
Dr prime is not equal
to 0 is greater than
or equal to the number of
r for which Dr equals zero.
And so that implies that
the probability of Dr
not equal to zero-- so
if you just choose an r,
this is now a randomly chosen r.
Not that others weren't,
but I'm treating it
a little bit differently here.
This was a specific r for
which Dr was equal to 0.
I made an argument
that you can always
get this r prime one-to-one
such that Dr prime is not
equal to 0.
And now going back to what
I had initially with respect
to the claim here where the r
here was a randomly chosen r,
I'm saying, thanks to this
little argument-- this line up
top-- I'm going to be able
to say this is greater than
or equal to one half.
OK?
Cool.
Any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think
the Dr squared times
column equal column
on the board.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: On the last column,
it should be i, not j.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
This should be i?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
People agree with that?
Majority vote.
All right.
I'm good.
Let's make that an i.
AUDIENCE: The iteration
of that as well, Dv sub j.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Oh, yeah.
Of course.
Yeah.
Once you do that, you
have to have an i there.
Good.
So you're looking at
a particular entry--
it makes a difference whether
you used a column or a row.
If I'd done-- now that I
remember-- if you turn this
into a row matrix and
this becomes a row matrix,
you'll essentially get the Dvj.
So it depends on which way
you look at it, but thanks
for pointing that out.
The specifics of i and
j weren't particularly
important to the proof itself.
The key thing is you zoom in on
a particular entry that is not
equal to 0, and then you
tweak that entry corresponding
to the r.
So once you tweak that--
you make that 0 or 1 or 1
to 0-- you can get this result.
I'm sorry.
I'm pointing to the wrong spot.
This result-- and
then get your claim.
OK?
So summarize-- we have a bound.
We run it over and over,
and we get it to the point
where we can have a
0.0001 probability that,
if the matrices were
multiplied incorrectly,
that you wouldn't discover
that because you ran it
for enough hours
independently chosen
that that probability
becomes as low as possible.
OK?
So that was Monte Carlo.
Let's do a Las Vegas algorithm.
And you guys are probably
thinking, my goodness.
Another sorting algorithm
after, I don't know,
17 different sorting algorithms.
This all sorting algorithms
that you've ever learned so far.
Right?
So merge sort doesn't
work, and the reason
it doesn't work in
practice-- if you're really
into performance-- is because
of the auxiliary space that
merge sort requires.
So if you recall there's the
notion of in-place sorting.
So let's move onto
the next thing
here, which is quicksort, which
is a new sorting algorithm.
And I want to motivate it
for just a couple of minutes.
And the primary
motivation really
is practical performance,
not asymptotic complexity.
So I'll be upfront about that.
It's all about
practical performance
corresponding to quicksort.
And quicksort is a divide
and conquer randomized
algorithm invented in '62.
Unlike merge sort, it's got
two interesting properties.
The first is that it's in
place, like I just said.
So no auxiliary space.
In Mozart, you can try
and get around this.
I should say order
n auxiliary space.
You need a little
temporary variable
in order to do a swapping.
But you don't have the
order n auxiliary space.
So you don't have to
constantly allocate.
And remember, n could be large.
It could be in the
billions or trillions.
So, from that
standpoint, quicksort
ends up winning simply because
of relatively mundane things
like memory allocation
in your computer.
And the other interesting thing
about quicksort in relation
to merge sort is that all the
work is in the divide step.
So in merge sort, remember we
just split, and we recurse.
And what happens
when you come back
is you have to do
the finger emerging
algorithm by looking at
the two sorted arrays
and looking at what the new
merger is going to look like.
So the work is in the merge.
But in quicksort, the work
is going to be in the divide
because we're going to have to
do a bunch of work associated
with figuring out how to keep
the partitions balanced--
a little bit like we had to do
when we did median finding back
a couple of weeks ago.
I'm going to talk about
three different variants
of quicksort.
The. variant that we're going
to spend the most time on
is the Las Vegas
quicksort where we'd
like to show that
it's probably fast
and make a statement about
the expected runtime.
But we'll get to that by
talking about a couple
of other interesting
variants, and this'll
be elaborated on to some
extent in section tomorrow.
So before we get to
variants of course,
let's try and set up the
structure corresponding
to quicksort.
And as always, we have
an n element array A.
You have divide that corresponds
to picking a pivot element, x
in A. And then we're
going to partition
the array into sub-arrays.
And what we have here--
this little picture
should make things clearer.
And you kind of saw this
in the median finding,
but here we go again.
Let's assume all the
array elements are unique.
We have L, E, and
G. L is less than.
G is greater than.
And so your pivot element is
going to break this array up
into L and G, where you
got all the elements that
are less on the left and
all the elements that
are greater on the right.
And you're going to
recurs on the L and G.
So recursively sort sub-arrays
L and G. Combine is trivial--
or merge is trivial-- because
you've already broken things
up thanks to the pivoting.
And you just concatenate
those arrays.
And that's why you
can do this in place.
There's no issues.
You're really recursively
sorting sub-arrays.
You are moving things
around a little bit
when you do the partition.
Obviously, the initial array
may have all the elements.
You may pick the pivot
such that the pivot
is all the way on the
right-hand side in the sense
that it's a very large element.
That is not necessarily
a good thing.
I will talk about that.
But if you pick an interesting
pivot or a good pivot,
you're going to have to move
the elements in the array
to the left of the pivot if
they're less than the pivot,
and you got to move the
elements to the right
if they're to the
right of the pivot.
Nontrivial piece
of code, not super
complicated, but you can
look at the CLRS page 171
to look at in-place
partitioning where
you don't have to use
another order n space to move
these elements around such that
they look like that picture
that I have up there, starting
from some random starting
point.
So you want to have the
picture that you have here,
and you need to go from-- the
very same array, it needs to--
and x is somewhere here, and you
got x plus 1 here and x minus 1
here, for example.
And you need to move
those things around
so they look like L, E,
and G, and that's something
that you can do in place.
And you can look at the
code for that in the CLRS.
I won't cover that here.
So let's look at a bunch of
different variants responding
to quicksort.
And there's some
real simple ones.
Each of these, we can knock
off with respect to complexity
and runtime fairly easily
with the one exception
that we'll spend
some time on, which
is the Las Vegas quicksort.
But we'll call these
different names.
Let's talk about
the basic quicksort,
which is also a useful algorithm
that people use in practice.
And amazingly, this algorithm
is simply something that says,
I'm just going to constantly
pivot on either the first entry
or the last entry.
So I'm going to pick
my pivot to be A1.
And when I pick
my pivot to be A1,
it's a value that I'm
talking about here.
X is a value.
It's not an index.
The A1 value-- maybe that's 75.
Then I'm going to create
my L matrix corresponding
to this pivot where all
the entries are strictly
less than 75, and G would
be strictly greater than 75.
And I could do that for A1.
I could do that for An.
So remember that the
pivot is a value.
Now, if I look at
this, I'm going
to do the partition, given
x, just like you saw there.
And this is going to be
done in order n time.
It makes sense that you're
going to look at every element,
and you're going to move it
to an appropriate location
to the left of x, which is
the e array, or to the right.
And you'll do that.
That takes order n time.
And, as I mentioned,
you can look at this
to see how this
is done in place.
So let's take a look at the
analysis of basic quicksort,
and what I'm interested in,
of course, is the worst case
analysis.
And I asked this
question, I think,
before when we were
doing median finding,
but what is the
worst case complexity
of the basic quicksort algorithm
that chooses the pivot as A1?
What is the complexity?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Order n square.
It's order n square.
And the reason for
that is that you
may have an array that is
sorted or reverse sorted--
depending on whether
you're picking A1 or An.
You can have a worst
case situation where
one side, L or G, has
n minus 1 elements,
and the other has 0 elements.
And so if you look at
our recurrence associated
with this, you could have
Tn, which is T0, plus T n
minus 1 plus theta n.
And why do I have
a theta n here?
Well, remember that I still
have to do this divide
step or this partition
step in order to compute
this up unbalanced array.
So I do have to look at
each of these elements
and do the comparison.
And maybe I don't actually
have to move them,
but I have to do the
comparison with the A1, which
is the x pivot.
And in some cases, if I'm doing
the wrong thing reverse sorted,
I also have to do the move.
Either way, I have a theta
n complexity associated
with the divide step.
And so if you go off and you
look at what happens with this,
well, you've got Tn
equals Tn minus 1
plus theta n, which ends up
with theta n square complexity.
So a hand waved a
little bit two weeks ago
for a similar analysis,
but you can kind of
look at it a little
more precisely
here by writing the
actual recurrence out.
And you see that you get the
recurrence Tn equals Tn minus 1
plus theta n, which
is an n square result,
or the solutions is n square.
OK?
So basic quicksort look bad.
It's got a worst case
complexity of theta n square.
It works well on random
inputs and practice.
And it turns out that it's
a fashion of algorithm,
partly because it's in
place and it's easy to code,
that what people do is
they take their inputs,
and they shuffle them.
You might get a bad input, and
it might take you a long time
to run.
But if you take an
input and you shuffle
it and you do that
in theta n time,
you just move things around
and randomize the input.
Then effectively, you
have a random input,
and this thing works
pretty well in practice.
Now, what is pretty well?
Well, we're going to
do an analysis that
is going to not be exactly
the analysis that you'd
have to do on basic
quicksort on random inputs,
but essentially, you can
say that basic quicksort
on random inputs is going to run
in expected theta m log n time.
OK?
It's something that you'll
see a little bit of how
to do that today and in section,
perhaps for median finding
in section tomorrow.
But that's all I wanted to
say about basic quicksort.
It's a practical algorithm.
It does require a little bit of
shuffling up at the beginning,
and then you can simply
use the pivot A1.
And because you've
done the shuffle,
generally you get
balance partitions.
The L and G's look balanced,
and you don't end up
with theta n square.
If you have any sort of
balance associated with the two
partitions L and G, you're
going to get a nice divide
and conquer, which is going to
give you your theta n log n.
OK?
So that's basic quicksort.
There's another way to
do this, and so this
is a question for you guys.
Suppose I wanted to use
the quicksort strategy
and get a worst case theta n log
n through an intelligent pivot
selection.
So I want to do a pivot
selection intelligently.
So how would I get under
the structure of quicksort
that you see up there
on the left there?
How would I select a pivot such
that I get worse case theta
n log n complexity?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Linear median finding.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
Linear medium finding.
Perfect.
That's exactly right.
There's a gentleman at the
back who'd raised his hand,
and I decided I'd chicken out.
I think one time to the back of
the room is enough for a day.
I'll have a Frisbee left.
Hopefully you can get one.
So the intelligence
pivots selection algorithm
is the median finding
algorithm because that's
going to guarantee
me that I'm going
to get balanced partitions.
If you tell me that
A1-- and remember,
we're talking
medians of values--
so don't get confused
with indices.
When I say something
is a median,
I'm talking about the
value, that given its value,
there are all these other n
over 2 values that are less
than it, roughly speaking
and n over 2 values that
are greater than it.
And so A1, I have no idea
whether it's large or small.
So I couldn't say much about it.
But if I want to
be worst case and I
want to guarantee that I
have balanced partitions,
I can choose the median.
And if I choose the
median every time,
I'm going to get perfectly
balanced partitions.
They're going to half on the
left and half on the right.
And we do know a way of
getting balanced partitions.
We can guarantee that balanced
L and G using median selection
that runs in theta n time.
And we showed that a
couple of weeks ago.
Now, that median selection
algorithm was nontrivial.
OK?
It had this weird thing
where you broke things up
into five sub-arrays
of size 5, and you
found a median of medians
et cetera, et cetera.
But we argued that the
whole thing ran in theta n
time, which is important.
And so now, if you look at
what happens with quicksort
and if I write the
recurrence for quicksort,
thanks to selecting a
median, I effectively
have balanced partitions.
So I have 2T n over 2.
This is thanks to the
median based pivoting.
That's important.
Otherwise it won't work.
And then, just to be very clear
here, I got two theta n terms.
OK?
The first theta n term is the
recursive median selection.
And then the second
theta n term is of course
the divide, or partition.
But it's important to
realize that now I have
a lot of work in the divide.
A lot of work.
I have to do an
intelligent selection using
this recursive median
finding algorithm.
And I also have to do the moves
comparing and then generate
and the G arrays.
OK?
So those are the two theta n's.
They're obviously theta n,
but I wanted to make it clear
that there's two
things going on here.
And we all know that that
is theta n log n worst case.
All right?
So there is a way of using the
quicksort structure template
and getting a theta n log n
worst case algorithm, which
doesn't work in practice because
it's just too complicated.
What's going on here is at
every level of recursion,
you're calling another recursive
algorithm to find the median.
So if you go code
this up, it loses
to merge sort in practice.
You can do all of this
in place, but because
of all these recursive calls, it
doesn't work well in practice.
But it's good to know.
And so this is a
good example I think,
which we don't do
a lot of in 046,
but you get a sense of the
difference between asymptotic
complexity and performance.
So while the median finding
algorithm has better asymptotic
complexity worst case, it
really loses in practice
to the basic quicksort,
which essentially
is a bit of a hack,
where you take an input
and you randomize
the input and you
run it with A1 as the
pivot or An at the pivot.
Is there a different way
that you can actually
get to a Las Vegas algorithm?
And it turns out
randomized quicksort
is something that you
can build and use,
which is a bit different
from basic quicksort
and certainly different
from median finding.
But it kind of has a little
bit in common with them,
and it's our example
of a Vegas algorithm.
So what happens at
randomized quicksort?
An x is chosen at random
from the array, A.
So you're not choosing A1 or An.
You might just flip-- well,
effectively an n-sided
die-- and pick a
particular index,
and then go grab the
pivot corresponding
to the value at that index.
You're not going to
randomize over values.
You don't know what
these values are,
but you can pick a
random index and then
grab the pivot based on
the value at that index.
And so at each recursion,
a random choice is made.
And the expected
time-- so now we're
saying something different.
We're making a stronger
theoretical statement
that the expected time, when
you do this, for all inputs
arrays A is order n log n.
And so now, this is
not worst case time.
It's expected time.
So this is going
to be our analysis
in the last few
minutes here to analyze
not randomized quicksort,
but a slight variant
of randomized quicksort
that is going to show you
that you can run randomize
quicksort and this variant
in order n log n time.
So not quite sure what's going
to happen in section tomorrow,
but the full analysis
is in the book.
You should read it.
As you can see, it's
a couple of pages
that includes the
description of a quicksort
that I have already.
But what we're going to do here
is analyze a variant quicksort,
which is a little bit
easier to analyze,
and it gives you
the sense of why
in fact the randomized
quicksort is
going to run in expected time.
And this analysis is easy
to do it in a few minutes.
So we'll do that.
And tomorrow, you'll see either
a median finding analysis
that's similar to that
analysis in CLRS or precisely
that analysis, depending on
what your TAs want to do.
So this particular
variant, we're
going to call
paranoid quicksort.
And so this quicksort
is paranoid in the sense
that it's going to be afraid of
getting unbalanced partitions,
and it's going to keep trying
to get balanced partitions.
So it's going to try to
get a balanced partition.
It's going to check,
and then if it fails,
it's going to try again.
And so at the end of
it, there's obviously
an expectation associated
with the number of tries
that you need in order to
get a balanced partition.
But it just sort of flips the
problem on its head and says,
you know what?
I'm just going to guarantee
a balanced partition
from a probabilistic
standpoint and it
might take me a little
bit longer to get there.
But that's what Las Vegas
algorithms are all about.
They're probably fast.
And once I get a balanced
partition, I'm in good shape
because I can go do my
recursion, and I get my divide
and conquer working properly.
So what is paranoid quicksort?
Absolutely straightforward.
You could probably guess
given my description.
Let's just choose a pivot
to be a random element
of A. Perform the partition,
and then values will repeat.
So we're going to go off, and
we say until the resulting
partition is such that
the cardinality of L
less than or equal to
3/4 of cardinality of A.
And the cardinality of G is
less than or equal to 3/4
the cardinality of A.
So I'm allowing you a
certain amount of imbalance,
but not a lot.
Right?
And that's it.
That's paranoid quicksort.
You obviously are doing that
in each level of the recursion.
And at each level
of the recursion,
your L and G are going to be, at
most, a factor of three apart.
So you might get 1/4 and 3/4.
If you're lucky,
you'll get 1/2 and 1/2.
But the worst case,
given that you're
going to be exiting out of
this loop, is 1/4 and 3/4.
OK?
So, as always, you have
a simple algorithm,
and it's not
completely clear how
you're going to get to
expected n log n time.
But it's not difficult.
Basically, what we had to do is
we have to try and figure out
what the probability
of a good call
is, over here, a
good pivot choice,
and what the probability
of a bad pivot choice is.
And we have to obviously--
given the potential imbalance,
we have to write the recurrence
associated with that,
but let's take a look
at the pivots here.
And what can we say about
the size as of L and G
if you just did a random pivot?
Well, a bad call is when
you get something in L or G
that is less than 1/4.
And a good call is when you get
somewhere between 1/2-- well,
roughly, if you look at
the choice of the pivot.
So what I have up here, is
If my pivot is out here,
I have a very small L,
and all of the
thing on the right
is G. If the pivot is here,
I have a relatively small L
and a large G. The pivot
is over here, I'm good.
I got 1/4 and 3/4.
If the pivot is over
here, I got 1/2 and 1/2
and so on and so forth.
And so this part is
bad, this part is bad,
and the middle part is good.
So that's all that
this picture shows.
So a call is good
with what probability?
Given that picture, a call is
good with what probability?
It's greater than
or equal to 1/2.
And so what you can now
write simply is if Tn is
the time required to sort the
array, essentially you can say
Tn is T of n divided by 4
plus T of 3n divided by 4
plus expected
number of iterations
in terms of getting a good
partition times C times n.
And there is a reason
why I'm putting
C in here as opposed to theta.
That will become clear
in just a second.
Because I can't really
apply the master
theorem to this given
what I have with respect
to Tn over 4 and 3n over 4.
So what I have here is,
I'm looking at the case
where I could get an
imbalanced partition,
but the imbalance is bounded.
So I'd have n over 4 on
one side and 3n over 4
on the other side.
But I'm not going to have
n over 5 and 4n over 5
or what have you.
And so that's the
two recursive calls.
So that's hopefully easy to see.
The part that is new here
is simply the complexity
of this code that you see
here, which is obviously
the randomized algorithm.
That's exactly where
the randomness comes in
because you're picking a random
pivot, and you're checking it.
And so this is going to run
a certain number of times.
And we can figure out
what the expectation
is in just a minute.
But I have C times n because
this is constant time
to choose a random number.
We'll assume that
performing the partition
is C times n or theta n,
and that's why I have this
up there.
So this, we're going
to call this Cn.
And so expected
number of iterations
given what I have--
what can I say
about the expected
number of iterations
using simple probability rules?
What is that?
2, right?
1 over p.
All of them are independent.
So this is 2.
So what I have here is something
that I think you might have
seen this before, but it's worth
drawing the tree out and seeing
it one more time in case
it didn't fully registered
the first time or you didn't
actually see it in 006
or recitation.
But what I now have is T of n.
I want to solve T of
n equals T of n over 4
plus T of 3 n over
4 plus 2 times Cn.
And, again, like I said, I
didn't put theta n in here
because, as you'll see,
when I draw this tree out--
because it's not a massive
theorem invocation-- it's worth
looking at it from a
constant factor standpoint
to really get the sense of
how all of this works out.
And so if I draw that
tree of execution
and I start counting,
basically what I have
is 2Cn up at the top.
I have 1 over 4
times 2Cn over here.
I have 3 over 4
And then this 1 over 4 might go
1 over 16 times 2Cn over here.
And this might go 3 over
16 times 2Cn over here.
And this would go, I guess it
would be 3 over 16 times 2Cn.
And then 9 over 16
times 2Cn et cetera.
So this is an unbalanced
tree because you
have an unbalanced
partition up on top,
and now you want to count up all
the work that this tree does.
If you collect up all
of the operations,
then that's going to
tell you what T of n
is because that's
all the work that you
have to do in order to finish
up the top level of recursion.
And what you can say is, if
you look at this side here are
all the way to the
right-hand side,
you're going to have log to the
base 4 over 3 times 2Cn levels.
So that's just simply every time
you're multiplying by 3 over 4,
when you get down to the number
1, and that's log of 4 over 3.
And then over here,
it's a little bit easier
to think about because
it's a power of 2.
You're going to have log of 4
to the base 4 times 2Cn levels.
And really, it doesn't
really matter honestly
when we go to asymptotics.
But is worth seeing,
I think, just
to get a sense of why it
all works out, regardless
of whether it's n over 4 or
a different constant here
or whether it's
balanced or unbalanced.
The tree looks a
little bit different.
It's sort of weird.
It's got fewer levels here
and more levels there.
So it's sort of tilted this way.
But eventually, you get down to
theta 1 constants down below.
And basically what you can
see-- if you just add it up--
is 1 over 4 plus 3 over 4 is 1.
1 over 16.
3 over 16.
Obviously, those
all end up being 1.
So you have 2Cn
work at each level.
And if you just go ahead
and be pessimistic about it,
there's a maximum of log
4 over 3 times 2Cn levels.
And that's pretty much it.
Obviously, now you can start
ignoring the constants.
You just keep the log here.
You don't care what the base is.
You got an n here.
So drop the 2C.
Drop the 4 over 3.
Drop the 2C.
And you get your n log n.
OK?
So that's pretty much it.
I'll stick around
here for questions.
But you got an example of
a Monte Carlo algorithm.
You got an example of
a Las Vegas algorithm.
And tomorrow in section, you'll
see a slightly more involved
analysis for something
that looks a lot closer
to the randomized quicksort.
So see you next time.